hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to my bathroom I don't know
why I'm welcoming you to that but I'm
filming in here because it looks pretty
too lighting and very nice with the
window and mirror and creating a like
gradient and crimp anyway so ever since
the last joy creation video there's been
a lot of concern about my health
like oddly enough I've been getting
emails and tweets about my need to get
sleep and I haven't been told to go to
bed since my mom told me they were in
bed when I was living in her basement
it's prepaid trip 20 to go so I
appreciate the concern but I also wanted
to reassure you guys that I am doing
just fine and I've been managing the
schedule for a long time and veterans of
the channel will confirm this like those
of you out there who have been watching
for 2 3 or 4 years will note that I've
always been laid I live my life in a
state of perpetual panic and I actually
established the schedule last year and I
said I'm gonna do this it's gonna be
eight twelve everyday and the lake
immediately two days later I totally
missed the schedule that I've been
struggling to maintain it ever since and
that's fine I do the best I can and when
Matt came along that helped me out
incredibly you'll notice that like as
soon as Matt started helping me edit
like things got way more consistent
because I was able to get his help on
editing videos and in the past few weeks
he hasn't been able to help me because
he's been taking care of stuff on his
own and that's totally fine but that
just leaves me back into my cycle of
life so I wanted to show you guys
exactly what it was to be a markiplier
in a daily life of my life
so here's
how's that nose is that nice it was good
right too much screaming just like all
my videos anyway that was panic in life
what [ __ ] em talk about me no no we
never know so that's basically an
exaggeration of what I go through my
daily life but I realized this morning
it wasn't too terribly much of an
exaggeration because while I was filming
that I got a text from someone that I
was supposed to meet 15 minutes prior to
the text and I was horribly late and I
had to cancel on him and that is the
entirety of my life wrapped up in one
moment so I live a very sporadic life
but that's because I have adapted to
this and that's the way that I approach
things I have so many things that I want
to do that I'm very scatterbrained it's
not into something that's a burden on my
life it's something that I've grown to
love because I love it is going to sound
really weird but I actually do love
staying busy and I love working because
I love what I work on and I love being
able to do this for my job and I've said
this many many times before I'm very
lucky to do this for a living and so
when I get an opportunity to work on
something cool like what I do on YouTube
normally or when I get a chance to work
on something outside of YouTube it
really inspires me to keep pushing
forward because I'd rather stay busy and
rather lose sleep right now in the prime
of my life when I'm able to focus 100%
of my effort on these things then do any
sort of over relaxing or something like
that
and I'm not even saying this a bad thing
to relax like definitely you guys out
there take time to relax assistance I I
don't want to I've got so much stuff to
do in so little time to do it I've got
so many projects that I want to work on
right now that I am so happy like I'm
happy to get up early I'm happy to pull
an all-nighter like I don't feel good
doing it but I'm happy like that I have
the opportunity where I'm working on
something that allows me to pull an
all-nighter like it's a weird dissonance
of like being tired and work overworking
yourself and also enjoying what you work
so much that you want to sacrifice
everything for it and that's what I've
always meant what I hope you guys find
the thing that inspires you to that
point you know the thing there's like
burns inside of you in terms of
motivation like this is my thing this
might think that I would rather dedicate
all of my time to doing than anything
else and I loved every moment of it and
I hope that you guys will eventually
find your thing that allows you to keep
pushing yourself harder than you've ever
been pushed before so with that said I
do appreciate you guys looking out for
me sometimes I don't look out for myself
sometimes I'm working so hard that I
forget to eat and various points and
then I eat way too much like recently I
just went to bj's not sponsored by PJs
but they have this thing there called a
bouzouki and Kazuki Kazuki does it
physically
that's a that sounds wrong it's it's
it's a pizza cookie it is a cookie pizza
and they put ice cream on it and then
they drizzle it with more sugar and it's
stupid you agree on that I don't eat
anything LT but it's good I'm not
sponsored by it just it's delicious 90%
of the things that I mentioned on this
channel are things I'm not sponsored by
it's just things that I actually like so
take that for what you will are we going
to go out into the sellout corner over
here don't mind me anyway so again
I'm very happy to do what I do and thank
you guys for being with me for so long
and thank you for putting up with the
late videos which oddly enough I think
this video is gonna be a little kiss-up
uh uh uh but anyway I just I just super
enjoy what I do and I'm happy to do it
every day so thank you everybody so much
for putting up with me and thank you for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye